[Música]
los cómics son algo difícil de tratar y
el universo marvel no es ninguna
excepción ya que a lo largo de los años
nos han presentado un montón de
entidades cósmicas o dioses entre
comillas proformas personajes que nos
presenten todos sabemos que sólo hay una
entidad suprema en marvel el ya conocido
one ago
o el uno por encima de todo que es la
representación física de los creadores
de los cómics es decir el ser más
poderoso y la realidad absoluta del
universo marvel pero siendo éste el caso
hace relativamente poco marvel los de un
concepto bastante interesante y es que
si existe una fuerza todopoderosa del
bien porque no habría existir una del
mal
ah
[Música]
el inmoral hall número 5 fue introducido
un nuevo personaje al universo marvel
una actividad conocida como el 1 por
debajo de todos con one beat lobo
descrito como la encarnación misma de
todo el mal en el universo y
potencialmente en el multiverso marvel
esta entidad fue encontrada por hulk en
la capa más profunda del infierno en el
fondo del multiverso al parecer esta
entidad poseía dentro de una barrera
mística conocida como la puerta verde
todo para evitar que causará caos por la
posible destrucción del multiverso a lo
largo de la historia del modo de juego
se nos revela que el 1 por debajo de
todos es el responsable de los aspectos
mutantes presentes en la energía gamma
ya que esta energía proviene de él en
otras palabras él es responsable por la
creación de holt y las demás criaturas
nacidas a raíz de la radiación gamma
cuando la bomba que transforma bruce
banner en joló explotó sale una pequeña
grieta en la puerta que tenía estrellado
al 1 por debajo de todos además de dar
paso a la creación de holt creó un
vínculo entre él y la entidad
lastimosamente hemos visto muy poco a
esta entidad así que no sabemos mucho
acerca del 1 por debajo de todos pero
por ahora lo que sabemos es que desde
que el incidente de la bomba ocurrió se
creó una pequeña grieta en la puerta que
lo tenía sellado por la cual trató de
escapar debido a que la puerta aún
estaba presente y lo habían sellado en
su propia dimensión no pudo escapar del
todo así que tuvo que poseer a distintos
huéspedes mediante la radiación gamma
para así intentar escapar del infierno y
consumir todo el multiverso
afortunadamente para todos la mayoría de
su poder aún seguía en sellado dentro de
la puerta verde haz que holt con un poco
de ayuda fue capaz de parcialmente
derrotarlo y mantenerlo sellado en su
dimensión por lo menos hasta que
encuentre una manera de salir y de
vengarse de él esta criatura se alimenta
del odio la ira y la tristeza de todo el
multiverso es uno de los seres más
poderosos actualmente en el universo en
los comics de marvel no sólo por ser el
equivalente explícito del uno por encima
de todos el dios supremo de marvel sino
porque es considerado capaz de destruir
toda la creación fue por eso que fue
sellado en donde nadie lo encontraría al
comienzo de la historia del inmoral holt
se nos da una demostración del enorme
poder de esta entidad pues la historia
comienza con un vistazo al futuro un
futuro en donde el 1 por debajo de todos
los
el infierno y poseer completamente a
bruce banner teniendo su poder completo
esta entidad estaba destruyendo
absolutamente todo a lo largo de todos
los universos ninguna de las entidades
existentes de marvel fue capaz de
hacerle frente e incluso el mismo
menciona que aniquiló a franklin richard
ya galactus como si de un juego se
tratara su destrucción era inminente y
nadie lo podía detener así que la única
opción que tuvieron fue enviar un
mensaje de ayuda a los banner del pasado
para evitar que la entidad escapara en
su dimensión ya que sabían que se
escapaba nada en el universo podría
detenerlo
lastimosamente este es un concepto
implementado hace relativamente poco en
marvel así que no ha tenido muchas
apariciones y no sabemos mucho más de él
pero se espera que en el futuro tenga
más protagonismo en las historias y
posiblemente sea causa de un conflicto
enorme en próximos cómics de momento a
raíz de esto no sabemos con certeza la
extensión de sus poderes o qué clase de
habilidades tiene ya que cuando lo vimos
estaba limitado a su dimensión en el
infierno y no podía usar ni la mitad de
sus poderes pero suponemos que en un
futuro pueden explorar más a profundidad
a este personaje y nos den la
oportunidad de conocer qué tan fuerte es
y si en realidad es el equivalente a the
one world of por ahora eso es todo lo
que sabemos del 1 por debajo de todos sé
que es un personaje bastante nuevo en
los cómics así que si no lo conocías
espero que te haya resultado interesante
si algún futuro se nos revela más
información de él
haré una segunda parte de este vídeo con
todos los datos de este interesante
personaje pero de momento cuéntame qué
te parece este nuevo concepto que están
tratando de implementar de un mal
absoluto proveniente del infierno y de
una fuerza absoluta imparable estoy
pensando comenzar una serie en donde
habló acerca de personajes poco
conocidos en los cómics que me parezcan
interesantes así que si sabes de algún
personaje del que quieras que hable
házmelo saber en los comentarios o en
twitter hasta la próxima
[Música]